I would never have gotten into acting
if it wasn't something like
the kid with the prosthetic.
Who here wants to be on camera?
So you never had been an actor before,
you never necessarily
had an interest in acting.
What was it about this show that you said,
"Yeah, that's like a thing I'd wanna do?"
Just to spread awareness.
It's a great way to inform people.
I guess that makes sense.
We have episodes
that are about Josh's prosthetic,
about it breaking
or about him adapting.
In some ways,
I'm most proud of our episodes
where it's, like, barely mentioned.
Right? He plays soccer.
He's very enthusiastic. Right?
He reads a lot of self-help books.
And he has one leg.
Uh, guys, listen...
I wanna make friends because they like me,
not because they feel bad for me.
Hey guys, it's Logan Marmino,
and the great thing about this show,
and the crew,
is that there are so many different voices
that represent everybody.
So... why don't we
go meet some of those people?
This is Miss Nandi.
One of the First ADs.
I'm Reggie Junior-Junior.
And who am I?
-You're Romy Senior-Senior.
-That's right.
Yo Yo, what is your job like,
and what do you do?
I put watches on them.
I put things in people's hands.
-Pretty cool job.
-Thanks.
I'd like to introduce you to Kiah,
our Production Accessibility Coordinator.
Yeah, so as the PAC,
I do a lot of stuff that's sort of like...
disability and accessibility together.
I get to hang out with Josh and you a lot
when we're doing things
that are leg involved or crutch involved.
Do you wanna see the sensory room?
I always wanna be in the sensory fun room.
-Aw yeah, then let’s go.
If you've got a headache,
you can hang out up here.
If you have sensory issues,
and you need a place with low light
and not a lot of sound,
all that's up here.
That's so cool.
Uh, well, I think they're calling me
back down to set.
-All right, go for it.
-Bye.
So, today on set we are doing
the Halloween showcase scene,
and they're actually
doing it right now, behind me.
And this is my gingerbread man costume.
Run, run, run, as fast as I can.
You can't catch me,
I'm the gingerbread man.
Somebody grab me a doctor!
Or a least a glass of milk!
I love the scene where Josh gets to feel
like he can go to school without a leg on,
and everybody was, like, cheering for him.
That was awesome!
The first scene
that I got to do in episode 6,
Josh's leg has broken at Halloween.
I wrote most of that scene
myself, personally.
And what an amazing experience it was,
to write a scene that I was gonna perform,
talking to, basically my younger self.
I used to never leave my house
without a prosthesis on.
I didn't go in public without one
until after college.
Being able to shoot that scene
in a moment in Josh the character's life,
when he's so vulnerable, on Halloween,
was so intense and meaningful
and emotional.
And it's given me
an even deeper appreciation
of all the elements and all the people
that it takes to make a show
like this happen.
All right, bring it in.
Let's hear it.
-Go... Pirates!
-Yeah!
-He-Yarrr!
Thanks for watching,
and I hope you enjoy.